hi i'm michael morris i am the deputy
electoral officer for the infrared city
council and i'm going to give you a
quick run through about the by-election
that's coming up
so a by-election happens where you've
got a sitting counsellor
who resigns during the term of council
within the three years
meaning that there's a vacancy created
amongst the council table so rather than
12 councillors we have 11.
we can't have 11 councillors because the
number is set during our representation
review process of how many councillors
we have on each
council so from chiropractic we have 12
plus the mayor
which means that if we have a vacancy we
have to fill it so anyone throughout new
zealand can
stand and become a candidate all you
have to do is
be enrolled to vote somewhere within new
zealand which given we've just had the
general election means most people
should be and then you all you have to
do is be nominated by two people who are
residents of
the embargo city district
so that includes bluff in case people
are wondering voting begins on the 26th
of january which is when new zealand
post starts
delivering the postal ballots if you
don't receive your postal ballot you're
free to come in and make a
special vote so just come into the civic
administration building or the bluff
service centre
the election day is the 17th of february
and poland closes at 12 pm